Sony Pictures and fight you to watch the
sequel to the superhero reboot the
amazing spider-man 2 as much a set up
for uh sinister six film you didn't ask
for as it is a sequel to the amazing
spider-man which you also didn't ask for
from the studio that already learned a
hard lesson about putting too many
villains in a spider-man picture comes a
spider-man film with too many villains
watch as suni makes all the same
mistakes they made with spider-man 3 the
movie responsible for rebooting the
franchise in the first place
well almost all of them the amazing
spider-man 2 partially tells the
underdeveloped story of Max an
electrician who works at Oscorp who is
sort of evil because he fantasizes about
choking Ryan Howard from the office and
has a shrine to spider-man in his
apartment max transforms into electro
after he takes on this insanely
dangerous job with a 100% chance of
something bad happening experience the
story of Peter Parker and his girlfriend
Gwen Stacy who bond and make out over
their shared guilt over dead parents
juggling a relationship and a full-time
job as spider-man is nothing compared to
his newest challenge finding the
treasure hidden by the Declaration of
Independence peter's adventure fades
into dark revelations about his father's
work that could change the course of
history and offer him a much needed
catharsis we thought we saw him get in
the last chapter critics are already
calling it the field of dreams of
superhero film with more relationship
drama than a meg Ryan movie yes I need
you and only 30 minutes more actual
spider-man scenes than a meg Ryan movie
including yet again saving a baby from a
burning building crawling through
tunnels doing this and whatever this is
spider-man
faces his greatest challenge yet as he
takes on the brother of dr. Manhattan so
that Sony can cock block Marvel from
once again owning the movie rights to
the character and speaking of
cock-blocking Leif Quinn the ghost of
Denis Leary is here to ensure that
spider-man sticks is Peter somewhere
other than Gwen making it
psychologically impossible for him to
Parker for the entire film
Sha Tin cartoon with little bits of
live-action added here and there you
won't believe it when you see this
movies world come to life on screen
there's actually not much you'll see
that you'll be able to believe
especially this kid seriously not one
cup could stop this kid from running out
into the street sit through a first act
that takes one hour to finally end only
to introduce you to a second act with
whiny Harry Osborn and his fake disease
retroviral hyperplasia and for at least
the 71st time here how much Harry hates
spider-man all over again you're a fraud
fighter man discover the beauty of
accidentally advancing the story through
absolutely insane blood devices come see
a motion picture that recycles all of
its plot from every other comic book
film including for the third time in 12
years the Green Goblin 360-degree
panoramic views of Times Square a main
villain who shoots lightning in the
middle of New York police cars being
thrown more funerals be prepared to ask
the questions
how does Harry know that the Green
Goblin suit will heal him when he uses
the spider venom
where did electro get the spiffy suit
that fits him perfectly and what's up is
this
experience Sony products at every turn
including this crappy TV Peter watches
that proves not one Zenith was harmed
during the production from a script by
no less than four people including the
guys who wrote the first two
Transformers movies directed by Marc
Webb wait a minute is that supposed to
be a joke
starring Eduardo slinger ed Malekith
Pepper Potts Django ungrounded steampunk
Pig Rama aunt Norma Rae that guy the
amazing spider-man 2 time we try to be
friends wait a minute doesn't being
friends pose the same danger only
without the sex
Peter why would you agree to this well
that was weird
click the link above to check out
everything wrong with the amazing
spider-man 2 from screen junkies and as
always subscribe